hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
how to limit patient harm from erroneous
results
qc strategies based on risk management
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio rad
laboratories i want to invite everyone
to participate by submitting your
questions during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we do not have time for
during the webinar
will be captured and responded through a
q a list
that will be posted next week in the
event resources box which is located
below the ask a question box you will
also be able to download the
presentation handouts
from this event resource box starting
september 17th
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply contact
us in the ask a question box
and we will address that issue
immediately
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers
free pace continuing education credits
click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right corner
of your presentation window and follow
the instructions to obtain
your credits so let's get started i now
present today's
first speaker mr john pacheco
john's performs research in quality
control and patient risk
issues for the informatics discovery
group at bio rad laboratories
john has had the opportunity to
collaborate with laboratories around the
world developing a practical
real-time interlaboratory quality
control
and proficiency testing systems as an
innovator he has developed numerous
ideas
leading to over 35 laboratory related
invention
patents around the globe all providing
new
and cutting edge solutions for our
diagnostics laboratories
for a complete biography on mr young
pacheco
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
john welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you and howdy everyone uh
i appreciate you uh you attending our
webinar here
and my goal is to talk a little bit
about and perhaps give you an
understanding of why
we should be thinking about risk-managed
qc so we'll spend a little bit of time
distinguishing risk-managed qc
strategy design and
and why that's necessary
and then we'll look at
what are so some of the things that i
want you to take away from this are
first of all to be able to identify
what do we mean by patient risk managed
qc strategy design
what does that mean how do you do it um
and one of the key elements as you'll
see is
that it is based around the severity of
harm
model for risk management and
uh hopefully everybody's going to come
away with an idea
about how do you set that severity of
harm category
for an analyte and then we'll talk about
when we have a qc design um
what are some of the things that we can
change that
will change the the risk of that qc
strategy
and so um specifically i want you to
come away with a couple components
of how what can i do to minimize patient
risk
in a in a qc strategy so
those are some of the three key
takeaways that i'm hoping everybody is
going to leave
this with and in order to get there
we're going to start with an overview of
risk-managed qc design
mean and why why is it
important and then we'll talk about this
iso risk model and severity of harm
and then how do we put all these things
together
and actually compute a risk management
index um and so what we'll see
is that a risk management index rmi
is a very concise way to summarize
exactly what is my the
the strategy that i have what's the risk
that i have
in my test method when it comes to
controlling the risk of patient harm
from erroneous uh results
well once we've got that foundation
underway
then we're going to take a look at how
do i actually use
this to solve qc
design problems with risk management
techniques
we're going to use a tool called mission
control in order to do that
which is basically a calculator that
will walk us through
the uh it's going to walk us through
the computations that we need and then
finally we'll sort of summarize what the
impact of this
type of of risk managed qc
design approach is so
why do we want to move to risk managed
qc
what are the benefits of doing that well
i would
say the primary benefit is that
risk-managed qc
focuses on the patient
conventional qc methods where we're
focused on things like
metrics like the probability of error
detection
are primarily focused on the instrument
so
our qc strategy design revolves around
how do we determine if there is a
problem on the instrument
and while that
is certainly something that we're
concerned about but
it doesn't take into account things like
how many patients are being tested
what's the utility of the the clinical
utility of the test method in question
uh and there are many things that that
it simply doesn't consider when our
focus is primarily on
is there a problem with the instrument
so
a patient approach
we have the primary metric is what's the
probability
that we're producing erroneous results
that
are going to harm a patient
and while those two things may seem like
they're similar they're very very
different
so when we start focusing on the
probability of producing erroneous
results
well that depends on how many patients
are we testing
in the presence of an erroneous result
and
things like what's our relationship
between the quality specification
and the test method performance
how does test method reliability play a
role
how what are we doing with these actual
results
are we using them in the context of
other
biochemistries or are we making
a decision purely based on this result
like we might do with perhaps
something like an infectious disease
result
where a majority of particularly if we
were looking at say a molecular
infectious disease result where
a majority of the decision is made
purely based on that result
and then of course the other thing we
have to consider is the number of
patients that we're
evaluating between qc events
and this approach also one other benefit
that it has
is that it doesn't assume that we have
uniform precision across the analytical
range
so almost none of our test methods
for qualitative clinical diagnostics
have the same analytical precision
at a low concentration as they do at a
high concentration
and that's something that we have to
take into account
when we're looking at designing qc
strategies
okay well what exactly do i mean by a
risk-managed qc strategy design
well we start with trying to determine
what's an acceptable level of patient
harm
now at first blush that may seem a
little
disconcerting what do you mean we have
an acceptable level
of patient harm well you know the
the reality is that there is
if you test enough patients you are
going to
produce erroneous results and if you
produce enough erroneous results
you are going to cause some level of
patient harm
so our goal needs to be that
we are keeping the level of patient harm
to an acceptable level and so the way
that we determine that acceptable level
is based on the clinical utility of the
test method
how are we using the results and then
we consider things like the quality
specification
test method performance how frequently
are there failures in the test method
what are we actually doing with those
results how many patients
are we testing between qc events and we
can use
all of those things to compute the
predicted probability
of producing patient harm and then we
want to find qc
strategies where the predicted
probability of patient harm
is less than the acceptable level of
patient harm
so this relies
on the iso model for acceptable risk
in iso standard 14 971
the application of risk management to
medical devices
presents a model for risk management and
determining
what is an acceptable level of
risk this same approach was also used
in ep 23
the clsi laboratory quality control
based
on risk management standard they both
use
this same risk model and the concept
is pretty straightforward
you use the risk model to just to assign
a severity of harm category
to each analyte and that category of
harm is based on
how are we using these these test
results in a clinical setting
and each severity of harm has an
associated
maximum probability of patient harm
so if we have a certain level of patient
harm
of course the greater the harm the less
our tolerance is going to be for it
and then that acceptable probability of
patient harm
gets used to determine just how many
um erroneous patient results can we
tolerate
so let's take a look at what the
severity of harm categories are
well they are divided into five
categories starting with negligible
and going all the way up to catastrophic
and it should make perfect sense to
everybody
that you know if we have negligible harm
the consequence to the patient might be
inconvenience or temporary comfort
discomfort
but we have a lot higher tolerance for
inconveniencing our patients
than we do for causing something like
serious harm
where it's impairment that requires
professional medical intervention and so
you can see these different
categories of increasing severity of
harm
and then we have a corresponding
probability
of patient harm and that's associated
with that
where we start at negligible uh where
we've got
an acceptable rate of one in a 100 and
then with each severity of harm
it drops by a factor of 10.
so the maximum acceptable probability
for negligible harm or inconveniencing a
patient
is one in a hundred and then that drops
down to
one in a hundred thousand for critical
harm or one in a million for
catastrophic
harm so that then
um gives us a way to actually
determine how much harm is acceptable
and it's based on the utility of the
actual
test method itself so
the severity of harm uh you know if we
think about
the the basic idea is that the more harm
we have the more severe a harm is
the less tolerance we have so just in my
little example here
uh you know you obviously have a lot
higher tolerance for touching bumpers
with the car in front of you
then actually damaging the car and of
course
but even having a fender bender like the
one in the middle
um you have a lot higher tolerance for
that then you end up
in a scenario where your car is
completely inoperable
and you've got it's going to take some
serious help in order to to make that
work again
so that's the idea behind the severity
of harm
concept for qc strategy design
okay well so what we want to do is we
want to
we want to focus on how do i determine
what's my probability
of producing erroneous results
um and there is a way that we can do
this computationally
so if i have that list of things that we
talked about earlier with a total
allowable error
that's the tea test method performance
and qc strategy
and the test method reliability well we
can estimate
what our probability is of producing
erroneous results
so the way that we do this
is that we compute the probability of
erroneous results
as the probability of producing
erroneous result role
added to the probability of producing
erroneous results
when we're out of control so that's kind
of how we divide up erroneous results
we can produce erroneous results when
everything's working fine
and we produce erroneous results or can
produce erroneous results
when we have problems so first we'll
look at
how do we estimate what that probability
of producing erroneous results is when
we're in control
well here is an example of
the distribution of measurement error
so if i start off with zero
measurement error you can see that in
the center of the graph here
you can see that my distribution is not
actually positioned
uh over zero and that's because we have
some measure of bias
in our system and
then just in this depiction we have
the limits set by the total allowable
error
so we have a lower limit of the
the the low limit of total allowable
error
and the upper limit of total allowable
error
and then we can see in green you can see
that
our measurement air distribution
has is a little past the upward limit of
total allowable error
so all of the distribution
that falls outside of those total
allowable error limits
that's going to be the probability that
we have a result
that is erroneous all right and there's
a way that we can compute that
uh so if i've got my performance metrics
basically what are the means and sds
that correspond to the
the qc lots that i've evaluated
for this material i mean for this test
method
uh when i've got a total allowable error
uh specification
well then i can estimate just what's
that probability
that we were just looking at what's the
probability that's contained
in these tails and so i can then take
that
probability and actually compute
what is my rate of producing erroneous
results
when the test method is working properly
and i can also
look at how does that change
as my my
percent of as as my
um air meth error rate
goes up so if i look at
at a plot here what i'm looking at is my
percent unreliable
what's the percent of my results that
are going to be unreliable
given the size of the air condition that
i'm experiencing
and so what we can see here is that as
the error rate starts to increase
it doesn't have a noticeable
impact on the percent of unreliable
results or erroneous results that i'm
producing
but when i get to a certain threshold as
the air size increases
so does the number of of unreliable
results that i produce
until eventually i get to an air
conditioned so large
that every test that i that i
produce in the state of this air
condition
is going to be erroneous or
unreliable so this is one of the key
characteristics that we want to look at
when we're trying to determine what are
the implications
of measurement error and what happens
when measurement air increases
how does that impact the patients that
i'm testing in the presence
of that air okay
so now you know we've kind of presented
a model for
in control now let's talk about out of
control
and unfortunately the estimating the
out-of-control
erroneous results are quite a bit more
complicated
and the reason for that is that
first of all they depend on as we just
saw
what is the size of the air condition so
the number of erroneous results that
we're going to produce
directly depends on the size of the air
condition
but it also depends on how long is it
going to take
us to determine that you know how long
it's going to take us
to detect that we have an air condition
so our primary goal for detecting that
is our qc strategy and our qc strategy
consists of the number of patients
tested between
qc events and for each qc event
how many qc materials am i testing how
many qc specimens
and what kind of a qc rule am i going to
use
well another thing that we need to
consider
is that there are we can categorize
erroneous results into two different
categories
um so some results are correctable
and some results are final so
if we look at this little cartoon of
of our our test method here
each vertical slash is a patient being
tested
the diamonds are qcs so i test a bunch
of patient specimens i test qc
my results are accepted so i continue
testing
and then i have an out of control
condition
so in the depiction here i have an
upwards bias my the
mean of my results has increased
and it's increased to the point that i
have
some results that are going to be
erroneous so now i'm producing results
some fraction of the results that i'm
producing
are outside of my total allowable
error limits well
that so that's indicated with those two
red asterisks
and then i have this first opportunity
to detect
this out of control condition but i
don't
why well unfortunately
statistical quality control is
probabilistic
and so our qc
rules do not have a hundred percent
probability of detecting uh
an error and so in this case we didn't
so it's you can see that this air
condition
is not so large that it's pushing
every specimen result outside the
quality specifications
only a fraction of them and now i've
passed qc
so we categorize
an erroneous result that's produced and
then we pass qc
as a final result because once we've
passed
qc we don't stop and look for erroneous
results
we simply continue testing because we
don't think anything
has happened because we just tested qc
so erroneous results that are produced
prior to an accepted qc
are final we're never going to have the
opportunity to correct them
and so we can see we continue testing
because we don't realize there's a
problem
and then finally after the second qc
event
we finally have a qc rejection
so when we have a qc rejection we can
stop and then take a look at the results
between
the the rejected qc
and all the patients that were tested
back to the last accepted qc
and see if any of those were erroneous
and then correct them so when we design
our qc strategies
what we really want to control is we
want to minimize
the final erroneous results so that's
what we're looking at
now this depends
on what's our probability of error
detection
well as i said you don't have certainty
that your qc strategy is going to detect
an
out of control condition um
each qc rule has a characteristic power
curve
and that tells me what's the probability
that i'm actually going to have a qc
rejection
based on the size of the out of control
condition
now there are two aspects to this
we have small errors um have
are unfortunately difficult to detect
with our
qc systems and it may require
multiple qc events so that's the bad
news
is that it's very hard to detect
a small error with our qc
of course the good news around that is
that because it's a small air
it's not likely to have a lot of impact
on our patient results conversely we
have
large air conditions well those are easy
to detect
but they have a larger
impact on the actual quality of the
results that we're producing
so given those two scenarios we can
let's take a look at what the impact is
here so
i've got power curves uh here for
running two qc's for a 1 2s qc rule
a 1 3s and a 1 4s and the way we
evaluate these
is that we look at the size of an air
condition
and when we see the
intersection between the power curve
and the size of the air condition we can
then see what is the corresponding
probability
that we're actually going to reject
well this gives us a metric that we look
at a lot
which is called for a given air
condition
what is our expected number of qc events
to detection how many how many qc events
is it going to take
before i actually get a rejection
and this is simply the inverse of the
probability
of error detection so
in this example that we were just
looking at if you were using uh
if you were using a 1 2s rule we would
detect a 2.5 s
error in basically about one qc event
if it was a 1 3s air it would take us
i'm sorry a 1 3sqc rule it would take us
two qc events
if we were using a 1 4s rule it would
take us almost
eight qc events well so that then would
lead you to think that
why would i want to do anything besides
a 1
2s rule
because that's going to have the lowest
number of
qc events to error detection and we'll
talk about
why that's not necessarily the best
choice always
but here is a graph of when we look at
the expected number of qc events
to air detection so this starts off
high when we don't have any air in the
system
and that's because even without the air
in the system
we still have a probability of a false
rejection
and what this is showing us is that we
want that to be
high so in this case we're over a
hundred qc events
between false projections and then as
our air condition grows it becomes
quicker for us to detect it until
finally now this
looks like it plateaus at zero but it's
actually plateauing at one
so once we get to where this flattens
out call it somewhere around
seven uh percent error as soon as we
run qc we're going to detect it and then
as the error condition grows of course
we're going to detect that
as well with just a single qc evaluation
okay well the reason that we don't want
to always just use
a 1 2sqc rule is because
of false rejections so
the false projection rate is what's our
probability of a qc event
that's going to reject when we are in
control
we would call this a false positive so
our false rejection rate we want it to
be as low as possible because
we are getting noise from our qc system
with the false rejections we don't
actually have a problem
but the qc is rejecting which means we
have to stop and we have to troubleshoot
we may have to shut down testing
until we determine that there is no
problem
so on that qc power curve that false
rejection rate
is what's the probability of rejection
when the size of the air condition is
zero so we're looking right up at
this region of the power curve
and just to give you an idea of what the
implications of this
are is that the false rejection rate for
a 1 2s rule
is basically 1 in 11 qc events
so that means if you're running 20
chemistries
and you're using a 1 2 s rule on all 20
chemistries
and you're doing two qcs you would
expect to have
multiple rejections even when everything
is in control
every time you run qc compare that to if
instead i could use a 1 3s
rule where now i'm at 188
and if i could use a 1 4s rule i'm
i'm at 7 000 almost 7900 qc events
so what this means is that
we want to use a qc rule that has
the highest possible
number of qc events objections
um because that will really cut down
on the number of problems that we have
in the lab
so given that what i want to do
is i want to find a qc strategy
that is going to have uh
that has enough power of error detection
but is going to have a low false
rejection rate
and what i really am interested in
looking at is
finding a qc strategy that has an
acceptable number of erroneous
false erroneous final results
for an air condition so how do we do
that
well because we've already talked about
the number of erroneous results that
you're going to get
depends on the size of the air condition
so what we do is we go across a large
range of air conditions
and compute what these final erroneous
results look like
when we do that you end up with a graph
that looks something like this
so as the air condition starts to
increase
so do our number of erroneous results
that we're producing but now what we're
looking at here are
final erroneous results so if you recall
from the other graph that we looked at
let me go back to it real quick here
when we look at just the number of
erroneous results
well that just goes up until it plateaus
and it never gets lower
because of course you know as the amount
of
air condition grows so does your
probability of producing an erroneous
result
but once we start looking at this
definition of
final erroneous results what we're
looking at
is what how large of an air condition
can i have
that i produce an erroneous result and
still pass
qc and this fortunately
it has a maximum why does it have a
maximum
because at some point i have
as the number of erroneous results grows
because the size of the air condition is
growing
eventually i'm going to get to the point
where i'm going to start detecting that
air condition
so it's no longer going to be a final
erroneous result
and eventually when the size of the air
condition gets large enough
well at that point then i'm not going to
produce
final erroneous results because i'm
going to catch it and this would be
correctable results okay
let's start putting this together here
so
we've talked about a way to compute
our predicted probability of producing
erroneous results
but what we really care about is what is
our predicted probability of
harm caused from erroneous results
and now the conservative approach would
be to simply say
that every erroneous result
can harm a patient but that's probably
not true for the most part for most
analytes uh so for instance you know
it's it's very likely
that every erroneous albumin result
does not cause patient harm
why well first of all we are probably
considering
albumin in the context of other
results and other biochemistries and if
you have a result that's really
way off then that would
would cause the clinician to question
the validity of that result
and that doesn't necessarily result in
patient harm
so we have this
probability of actually a conditional
probability of harm given an erroneous
result
that probability of harm given an
erroneous result is going to be
one if you assume that every erroneous
result causes patient harm
but it could easily be much lower than
one
based on the quality specification and
the clinical utility of the result
well now we've talked about how we can
compute
a predicted probability of harm
and then we've talked about how do we
find the acceptable probability of harm
using the severity of harm
model well we define a patient risk
management index
as the ratio of predicted
probability of harm divided by
acceptable probability of harm
this is we call the rmi the risk
management index
and if that's at one or less then you
have managed risk
and it allows us to assess exactly
what the risk of patient harm is
under a lot of different circumstances
so i can compare that i can
easily see am i managing my risk of
patient harm
even though i may have very different
circumstances
i may have different rates of failure
i may have different severities of
patient harm i may have
different patient volumes that i'm
testing all of that gets
wrapped up together in one single metric
that will tell us where are we when it
comes to risk management
so let's take a look at how we actually
use this
so here i'm going to just i've got an
example for
a glucose procedure and
these are all the metrics that we've
talked about
so we've got a quality specification of
10 percent
i'm testing 100 patients per day i have
two qc events that i'm using with two
levels
here's my statistics for the qc my
performance
statistics and the qc rule that i'm
using
well i've determined that for glucose
and the way that that the results that
i'm producing
are being used that the severity of harm
category
is serious so that maps to
an acceptable probability of harm a
maximum acceptable probability of harm
of one in ten thousand then i also have
a reliability here where my mean time
between
failures is 90 days so if i
put all of these metrics into this
calculator
called mission control it's going to
compute
what my risk assessment is and in this
particular case
i really want to consider two outcomes
first of all i want to see what is my
rmi so in this case
it's pretty low it's 0.153
and i can also see that
most of that risk is coming from the out
of control side but it's still very low
and my in control rmi is is about
half of my uh out of control rmi
now i can also see that you know based
on
my qc stream i have an expected time
between false rejections
of about 52 days okay
so i have risk manage qc here
but what i would really like to do is
take advantage
of having such a low rmi
so this is the rmi curve
at when we have zero error this would be
the in control risk um
is at .05 and then i take
the area of the
the curve here in order to compute my
out of control
rmi and when i add those together i get
.15 and you can see
that my rmi which is this blue dashed
line
is well below 1 which would be in
control which would be
risk managed qc okay
so what can i do with this well
my expected time between false
rejections is 52 days
that's not horrible but glucose is not
the only thing that i'm testing
and so what i would really like to do is
take advantage
of this low rmi and see if i can
lower my false rejection rate well
if i first try a 1 3s rule
i end up with an rmi of 0.26
which is certainly better but you know
what i'm going to go
all the way up to a 3.5 qc rule
and when i do that my rmi
is still 0.73 so
i still have managed risk
but let's look at what this does for us
so
if i'm using a 3.5 qc rule
now my expected time to false rejection
is 537 days
so i've basically increased by a factor
of 10
how many times how many days i'm gonna
go between
qcs i mean between false projections
um and i still have managed risk
so this is one way that you can use
um the a low rmi
we can choose a qc rule that has
a much lower false rejection rate and
even though
that does increase our risk we still
have managed risk
but now we have taken advantage
of of our capacity to
dramatically increase the number of days
that we go
between false rejections okay
let's take a look at another example
here
so now i've got a sodium procedure
i'm testing 600 patients a day with
two qc events i'm using
a repeat 12 sqc rule
my severity of harm rate is serious
but here i've determined that really
we have a pretty high tolerance for
sodium results that are
outside of this quality specification
and i have a lot of failures on this
test method
so my sodium procedure
does not have a very high reliability
when i put this into the system
and evaluate it well i have unmanaged
risk
my rmi is 1.41
now not only is it 1.41 but when i look
at the decomposition here
my out of control rmi is over
one so that means that
what does that mean well this is what
this curve looks like
we need to do more qc because my out of
control condition
is causing too much risk so
in this case and last time we took a
look at what happens when you change
qc rules but in this case i'm already
using
about as powerful a qc rule as i can use
so instead i need to look at changing
the number of patients between
qc events and so what we're going to do
in this case is
we are actually going to do more qc
events
to drop the number of patients from 300
between qc events down to 150.
well when i do that i end up with an rmi
of just under one so i'm right at the
verge
of i still have risk manage qc
um but now i'm i'm actually
you know i i am not above
i don't have unmanaged risk um
my expected time between false
rejections
is not at 26 days but at least i've
managed
to to
detect air conditions more quickly
which reduces my risk and so this would
be a final
the final design that we might use for
something like this
so with these examples um
this just gives you a couple of examples
of
what you would how would you use risk
managed qc
strategy design so the number of
patients between qcs
the qc rule itself that i'm using
these are all factors that are going to
play into
what is the actual risk that i have of
producing erroneous results so
using a risk managed qc strategy design
i can using the the way that the results
are used clinically
to determine what is my acceptable level
of patient harm
and then i can compute what my
probability
of producing erroneous results are and
use that
to estimate my predicted probability of
harm
and then that gives me an idea of
what kind of qc do i need to do to make
sure
that my predicted probability of harm is
going to be
acceptable and so
some of the things that we have to
consider are what's the qc
strategy our specification the qc
strategy itself
how frequently am i doing qc what qc
rule am i using
how much qc and then what is my test
method performance
because the test method performance is
going to affect all of these things
and then i also if i think about when
i'm looking at
my out of control estimate of
how many erroneous results are produced
when i go out of control
well it it depends on how frequently
am i going out of control so we have to
have an estimate
of what the test method reliability is
and now i also have to consider
patient volume because
when i go out of control how many
patients are going to be impacted well
that depends on the
the number of patients that i'm testing
between
qc events and now the other thing
that i want to point out here
is that unlike conventional qc
design risk managed qc design
allows you to reduce the false rejection
rate
with additional qc so
that may not be um be obvious but
when you are in a scenario where your
[Music]
your expected time between false
rejections
is simply too low well if i do more qc
i can increase that so the more qc i do
that becomes a management decision if i
want to
decrease my number of false rejections i
increase the amount of qc
okay so in summary we use
the way that a test is actually acted on
clinically
to determine our tolerance for producing
erroneous results and then based on that
we try to find a qc strategy
that is going to have
a predicted problem
arm from earliest results that is going
to be below
the acceptable probability of patient
harm
and we can represent those relationships
with a risk management index an rmi
that makes it very easy for us to tell
whether or not we have managed risk and
what the implications are
an rmi of one is managed risk
an rmi of two you have twice the
acceptable level of risk
and so we can then use the rmi to find
suitable qc strategies that are
optimized for
patient risk and false rejections
thank you very much
thank you john for that great
presentation we will now
start the q a portion of this webinar
and if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now
just simply click on the ask a question
box located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have quite a few questions
coming in john
our first question from our audience
member is how should harm
be categorized when there are multiple
clinical
applications for an analyte
thank you um that's a great question
so we have to consider if we only have
one test method so let's just let's take
for instance we look at something like
glucose
and that test method is being used both
for screening
and it's being used for therapeutic
monitoring
well you could say that the severity of
harm category for those two different
clinical scenarios
is is going to be different well but we
only have one test method
so we have to pick the most conservative
severity of harm meaning we would pick
the highest severity of harm
for the various clinical scenarios
thank you for that and is there any
reference for risk
in general by test since all the
laboratory measures the same analytes
so in general there's not a an
actual there's not just one
reference and the reason for that is
that
the the way that patients are treated
based on results from a test varies in
clinical settings
and so there's not just a universal um
a universal reference now we have
working with labs
to try to categorize uh
you know how they are ranking severity
of harm
for for different analytes um that's a
work in progress
but even with that you really have to
consider
the way that results are used in a
particular clinical setting
in order to determine what the severity
of harm is
thank you john and what should we do
when we have no quality specifications
available
like a molecular testing or serology
okay yeah that's kind of a tough one
so all of this depends on having a
a quality specification and and in a lot
of circumstances
there's not universally agreed on well i
guess most circumstances are not
universally agreed on
test specification i would say for
something
like a molecular test
where you know if you're looking at
something like pcr
you would use something some kind of a
specification
around when would
when would the results have a different
implication
and so maybe when there's a three-fold
change or something like that
that you might consider that um
in general the the basic idea is
you want to set a quality specification
on when would the clinical decision
change
based on the performance of the result
thank you and i want to thank our
audience members these are great
questions coming in
john does someone need to design
their qc for each analyte and how can
they manage that in a lab
that's a great question um yeah the
logistics of this
so first of all in a perfect world uh
if you do qc design for each analyte
that's how you
optimize things so the more qc designs
that you can tolerate
and where this gets particularly tricky
is that not only do you need different
qc rules
for different scenarios you also need
different qc frequencies
and so logistically this can be a real
challenge for a laboratory
most laboratories probably can't
tolerate more
than three qc schedules
um however i think the the solution
would be eventually there is
instrumentation that's available today
and there's more instrumentation that's
coming that will allow you to
set qc strategies by analyte
and then the instrument just takes care
of it so if i want to say i want to do
qc for glucose every seven patients
um then i can do that and it just
happens
but it absolutely is driven by the
logistical considerations of the
laboratory
and just in general the more
specific qc design that you can do
well and that's going to be the the more
optimized your set of solutions is going
to be
but as as a starting point it has to be
based on what's logistically possible
for the laboratory
thank you for that and our next audience
member asks
are lab report patients results all
through the day
how can i manage the risk
ah that's that's a great question so
um what that means is that they're not
holding results until you
until the next qc um
the the ideal scenario is that
you don't release results until you've
passed qc
but that is not actually uh in a lot of
scenarios that simply
does not happen and so
what you have to look at then is
the design consideration that we talked
about still
works you simply have to be aware that
the risk
goes up when you are releasing results
because your opportunity for correcting
them
may be diminished um and so the other
thing to look at is
okay even though we're releasing results
all through the day what is the actual
time
that it takes for somebody to actually
review a result
so if
it's routine that results are reviewed
in say four hours after they've been
released
and we're doing qc every three hours
then this is not a consideration
but if results are being reviewed say
within
five minutes of release and i'm doing qc
every four hours
well then my risk is absolutely higher
and i don't have the luxury of of
looking at
all of these correctable results
the other thing that i would say is that
you have to be aware then
that you may have you may have to
issue corrections much more frequently
than you
otherwise would because if you have a
failure and you've already released
those results
well now you don't have the luxury of
correcting those before they're actually
released and so under those
circumstances you
have to be prepared and make sure that
you
don't go to too many patients between
qcs
so that it would overwhelm your ability
to correct a scenario where there's
where you know you've you've had a major
failure
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
when i have a 1 3s error
but my results are still within my total
allowable
error limits can i report my patient
results
thank you that's a great question so the
first thing i would say
is that the fact that you have a 1 3s
error
is is not what you need to be looking at
what you need to be looking at
is what is your designed qc strategy
so if your design qc strategy is that
you have a 3.5
standard deviation error is when you
would reject
then you wouldn't pay any attention to a
1 3s error
so the the the actual
qc rule that is designed
is what you should be paying attention
to now
certainly if you have a a rejection so
let's say for instance
that your designed qc
is a 1 3s rule and
and you have a 1 3s rejection well at
that point what i would do is
to take a look and we determine that
that one 3s projection
was actually indicative of a problem
in my test method so what i would do is
go back
and then take a look and review the
results
and take a look at just how many results
are actually at risk if we know that
we have this type of a bias in the
system
so that may require that you actually
need to run some additional qcs
you need to fix the error and then run
some more qc's so that we can
characterize what was the air state that
i tested these patients under
and what's the bias between that and the
corrected state
and at that point we can then take a
look at
and judge okay what is the
you know what's the probability that
these patients are
actually gonna have have um
air conditions that are going to have a
clinical impact
uh and that's what you would look at now
it gets tricky
simply looking at the qc results
in the context of the total allowable
air condition
because these are individual points
and so you can have for instance half
of your patient population be
unacceptable
and still have a 50 chance of having a
qc result
within that total allowable air
condition so it gets a little bit
complicated
but in general if you have a qc
rejection
that identifies a failure in your test
method
then you need to correct the failure and
then
assess did that failure produce
patient results that would uh
would that could cause problems
clinically
[Music]
mr john young thank you again sir for
your time today
for your important research and before
we go i want to thank our audience
members for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today will be answered and posted in the
event
resources by the end of next week the
webcast
will be available on demand in the
auditorium from friday on
and if you found this informative and
helpful please share it with your
colleagues
biorad will be hosting a new qc related
webinar
every month this year next month's topic
is the benefit of using an independent
quality control
and will be held on october 21st please
check back regularly on new topics and
take care
to explore our posters and our booths in
the virtual conference
until next time everyone take care and
be safe
thank you bye